get the customer to love
yeah your solution to to talk about it
in an emotional
state
uh and there there is this uh kind of uh
in the last couple of years people say
oh ask your customers
uh how would they feel if you take the
solution away right that's kind of the
test
so you want them to use the solution you
use full story use whatever
method to see their engagement within
the platform
see where they need help with
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
let's talk about permissions security
compliance and enterprises meet and
bernoy co-founder and ceo of optimize
prior to co-founding optimize dotan led
the product management for the infinity
next platform at checkpoint software
following the successful acquisition of
forced knock security where he served as
co-founder and ceo he also founded and
served as ceo of resect tech the time is
also a member of the technical board of
the governors israel institute of
technology
this is one hell of an episode welcome
to tan
welcome to 20 minute leaders authomize
great to be here thank you for having me
thank you very very much for coming i
love what you're doing i love the space
that you're in
i very very much love your investors and
so we already talked about that before
but i'm really excited to get to know
you better over these next 20 minutes
and get to know authomize in the space
that you're in and and really you know
rigorously thinking why is now the right
time for a company like automize you
know this idea of permissions and and
you know company it's been going it's
hundreds or thousands of years ever
since we had some sort of hierarchical
structure in society but now we have a
startup that raised a wonderful series a
called optimize and i'm excited to hear
uh why your experience spans much much
broader than than optimize whether it's
from your time at bagilan and the
technion and
you saw the previous company to a
checkpoint
force knock and and risk technologies
ltb
so i i really want to push forward now
because 20 minutes is way too short tell
me a little bit about what led to your
conviction
to start optimize uh with a good friend
ron lieberman
yeah so about a year and a half a little
bit
but maybe a couple of months more
we started authorized with three
partners uh
gal diskin our cto and co-founder uh was
the city of severa that was acquired by
palo alto he then led the palo alto
israel
and the entire traps and the cortex
solution within palo alto and won
liberman that you know well
from the cursing in hebrew a200
telpiyot which is the code name for
cybercyber
and we started really doing things by
the book we started a
process of ideation talking to dozens of
cios and csos from different verticals
different company sizes
in order to validate
our
assumption about managing authorization
and we started looking at oppa the open
policy agent
we thought that's an interesting
direction but when talking to the
different
executives the different managers we
understood that
this is kind of a small piece of a
larger picture that is missing which is
the authorization management the the
overall
and you're right authorization is done i
don't know i don't know about thousands
of years i can imagine i know who can
enter the cave and what they can do
within the cave is kind of a
authorization uh but um
but uh you're right the arbuck model the
role based access control exists from
the 90s and then
we had 2002 we had the sox regulation
coming in to effect making uh the
monitoring the governance uh identity
governance as a kind of a
given that every company every public
company needs to do
but since then not a lot change around
the authorization
and that's
and that's kind of uh
created a void because the world did
change cloud appeared and the
adoption of sas applications and so on
so i can dive into that even more if uh
but i don't want to
oh thanks so
so if you look at the last 10 years and
you look at companies like octa
um
you can look at companies like uh
all the zero trust companies so there
was a lot of changes within the security
space in the last 10 years right the
xero trust the sso the octa
casbies
and then this did not happen in a void
this happened to address something that
that the customers needed because they
started adopting more and more cloud
application they moved they moved to aws
to azure to gcp they they started opting
different ways of doing business
but when you look at the authorization
side of things how we are managing who
has access to what this is kind of the
authentication but what they
what they can do and after they log in
that's still
mostly based on defining a role defining
groups defining roles to that group
defining so it's manual so when you
onboard someone to your organization and
you define what they can do then they
start opening permission requests you're
fixing and you're changing what they can
do and then when they move the different
position you make those changes again
and then when they leave the
organization you need to make sure that
you actually took away everything and
this all what i'm describing is mostly
manual
you get to fortune 500 companies that
still have excel sheets and they they
have uh one of the big four coming every
year to fix the r back model um
when they need to do user access reviews
where they need to understand
actually what an identity what a user
has within different resources they need
to go to different applications
separately
and it was obvious that even if gal ron
and myself will sit in cancun drinking
pina colada waiting and looking at the
stars
that uh
there is a new category that's going to
emerge that that will disrupt this
entire way of doing authorization
management
so author
what i really want to ponder here is
2021 authorization management tell me a
little bit more about the need because
at the end all everything that we're
talking about here is causing delays to
the organization right every time that
they that somebody has to wait for
permissions i've been on both ends
inevitably it's going to delay some
operations you're giving less freedom to
the employees why is it so critical
today
and why has it evolved so much over the
last 15 20 years like you mentioned
yeah um so
so imagine there's two things one is the
operational side and the other is the
security
so those are two end of a different uh
aspect so i can say everything everyone
is admin
no delays in operation everyone can do
so i have 300 application
new employee comes in is admin on every
on each one of those
from now on i promise you there's not
going to be any deal nobody need will
come and say i don't have access to
something
they have access to everything all the
time so operational wise this is
extremely easy
uh to manage security-wise this is
extremely risky i wouldn't recommend
that
as a way to go and then the other side
of things is let's try to
close let's start to be more strict
let's try to reduce the risk and this is
the challenge how can we do that still
keeping the operational
side of things not to explode but kind
of keeping the risk
as low as needed how we can make sure
that a user or a human user as well as a
machine identity which is another topic
in itself
gain only the access they need
and when i say access is needed a lot of
time people imagine oh you're going to
strip a lot of permissions yeah that's
one side of the things but the other
side is
if you're doing your work well if
optimize works well that we can actually
recommend
adding permission to someone that is
likely to need
so it's finding the right balance it's
not necessarily just tripping away
permission
and
and when you have on-prem
oracle
sap something and that's your main
applications and not a lot of changes
not a lot of movement within the
organization
the arbuck model from the 90s can work
when you have
30 percent
change in your application on a yearly
basis employees coming going
and you're trying to keep the velocity
of your organization of your operation
you cannot do that manually
and
you need
you need a2c you need something that
looks at the identity looks at deep in
the granularity of those applications to
the assets understand the relation
between them and then makes your life
easier
right
and so when you're looking today
at companies and how you are built as
you're building automize and and and
soon i'll want to go back to the the
prediction side of things because i
think that's something very very
interesting what are you learning or
what have you learned through working
with enterprises already regarding the
way that
you know that the different stakeholders
are treating authorization within the
organization and and the willingness to
adopt you know a new startup that is
coming and going to be working
internally within the core of how the
organization functions operationally
yeah so authorization as a whole sits on
three legs generally it sits on the
security on the operation and the
compliance
so we are focusing on mid market so
compliance and security com comes
together uh and
this is kind of our first step security
wise so what we see from organization is
because we are a sas because it's
extremely easy to deploy us
uh as long as you really have a
fine-tuned understanding on both sides
of the use case of the problem you're
trying to solve
then the process works really fast and
the value and you can get time to value
which is
days
so once we have a
customer we define the application they
need to help with it could be
aws office 365 salesforce and github for
argument's sake
and you def and you then integrate to
their idp the azure active directory or
octa or ping
you get the information within optimize
authorize does the magic we analyze that
and we are then able to say
here is what we see here is what needs
to happen now you can define guard wells
now you can run user access reviews all
of that within the optimized platform in
in the your tip of your fingers very
easy so
so as long as things are defined and the
other thing the other insight is
i would say that for us that was that
was this is part of the opportunity when
you deploy an octa
your vision uh octa is your sso your
vision is that octa will be
integrated to the entire stack you have
300 application great i need octa on for
those 300 applications all the time
when you look at authorization
authorization comes into play
specifically in your critical
applications
where your data is the most
most the most sensitive information is
there where uh where your crown jewels
are
so
it's gonna be office physics five it's
gonna be your gate it's gonna be your
drive box dropbox it's gonna be gcp
it's gonna be a jira it's gonna be
applications and this is not just named
operating this is
uh application we have out of the box
connectors and you can connect us
extremely easy so so
it's going to be a list between five to
15 applications that you need to support
in the organization and do it well this
is what we bring to the table so it made
our life very easy as uh
paint me a short picture if we're
looking two three years down the line
you know you're moving very very fast
with optimize you have an incredible
team
and working with you and and incredible
also investors that are that are
powering you and
what where is the how is the world
different in two three years things to
optimize
and then i want to touch a little bit
back on on your previous experiences
yeah so
um so as i focus we as i mentioned
before we are focusing on mid market
so uh this is somewhat similar plate
what octa did
and then moving to the enterprise
that means that we took a challenge of
being an intuitive easy to deploy easy
to use solution you can plug and play
and manage your authorization
and i was really surprised uh talking
with the friends in the industry giving
lectures in a few that even companies
that are extremely small 50 people a
hundred people
uh
came and said we need that and um it's
it's amazing to see that even when
you're 50 users or 75 years old 200
users and someone left the organization
you don't know whether or not they still
have
uh
someone did a local account in
salesforce and you didn't know about
that and they still have access to that
information or so so the need exists in
both the enterprise but the uh the small
customers uh as well
we are focusing on the meat so you asked
me about the big picture we see
ourselves as kind of building a model
very similar in
octaves model
of being
moving really fast
addressing this mid-market that has the
need being their first and last
authorization management solution
and then moving within the organization
to help those organizations with the
security with the compliance with the
operation
so there's kind of a
lend and expand with this backed off
more and more application that you can
connect us to help you manage and more
and more use cases in the different
domains that we can help you with
so
in my vision in three years when you
integrate
optimize
it will take you
minutes
and
the value will be
almost immediately and each one of the
different department will be able to
have
the uh in the the ability to say oh i
have a i have a i have a need now to run
because of compliance user access review
that's easy for me or security i have a
policy that i want to enforce
that external uh i'm doing i have
subcontractors they have access to
different resource i want to have a
policy around that great or i have an
rpas i have uh robotic process i have
machine identities
machinery which is a pain i think the
next year will be all around everyone
will talk about machine identities how
do i know
because i i can't talk to a machine
there's no that it will not answer me
and nobody has the uh
it's extremely scary to take one of
those identities down because you don't
really know what they're supposed to do
who set them up and so on so and it
could be that the one that actually
added them is gone he left the
organization so you don't have anyone to
ask so
so this is there's kind of this entire
uh
from security perspective
visibility and observability of what's
going on within the organization my
ability to
set up
those guard dwells in violation this
policy i want to enforce
and then in the operation side we want
to make uh the so there's no reason for
let's say permission request there's no
reason that a human will get the ticket
will start stretching his head and then
i call it art make a decision because he
has a lot of experience in the
organization and he knows from past
experience that to answer this
permission request he needs to add you
to this group
but if someone else would got that
ticket they will add you to a different
group both of those will give you
permission to the resource you ask for
but the question is which one is better
which one is the true
uh way of solving that permission
request so we need to make that science
and
let the human
get involved only where
you need them otherwise the uh
machine the ai can do that better and
faster a hundred percent 100 percent now
a serial entrepreneur
founded companies previously acquired by
one of them acquired by checkpoint
what
as your as you're thinking back now on
the last year and a half
what comes to mind in regards to some
things that you're bringing with you
that you brought with you from your
previous experiences that that a
first-time entrepreneur may just not
even be aware of because it's not
trivial something very you know an
internal conviction that you have with
you that is either giving you confidence
or is just helping you push forward
so
yeah a great question so
as i kind of stated before we are we're
working very um
very neatly by the book the ideation
process was a lot of israeli
entrepreneurs are very strong when it
comes to the technology
and uh
many times i see them building something
and then start testing it with the
customer and they they actually start
building it before even talking to real
customers
um so you need to relax don't write any
line of code first of all talk to
customers getting the feedback and when
you talk to them don't try to sell them
their solution understand their problem
their side of the uh
their side kind of their problem what
they are trying to solve what their
priorities are
uh who's the body even who's the budget
owner we i'll give you i'll give you a
golden tip
every call you're going to have not just
with customer but every call you're
going to have let's say that you have 45
minutes talk with a customer
and you're telling them you already have
a solution you're trying to convince
them it's the best solution in the world
you're having the conversation leave the
last 10 minutes of the call to talk
about the process
to understand how things are
going to happen with this organization
what's important for them who's the
people you need to get to to get
involved in that process what's the
decision uh process uh what's the buying
process and so on
um
resec
is a network security
so originally when we need to deploy
that was like in the old world you came
to a customer's site you well covered
but imagine before covet if you remember
millions of years ago before corona
before the covet we actually met with
one another so we came to a customer's
site we told the customer it will take
you a couple of weeks it took three
months we deployed that it started
working it was inline right it was uh so
the conversation was how gonna do active
active are you gonna do passive active
are you gonna so the redundancy right
the availability
and blah blah blah and then when so that
was a real pain extremely hard to sell
uh from this perspective of the
integration as a process
huge process
and then
which involve a lot of people and then
force knock was
here is a vm it's already packed ready
deployed at
um
it was
much easier much quicker customers can
test the solution quicker and now i'm
actually even in an
easier world right everything is api
based we are sas so
but
so so the integration is easy
value is quick
now the challenge is making sure that
before you do the integration everything
is aligned
the customer and you understand why
you're doing it understand the value
they're going to see
are set they have the resource to
to use that right and then once it's
deployed it kind of moves to in our case
to what we call the customer success
right you want to make to show them the
value out of your solution
um i like the model of the 30 60 90 but
kind of making a long story short is
get the customer to love
yeah your solution to to talk about it
in an emotional
state
uh and there is this uh kind of uh in
the last couple of years people say oh
ask your customers
how would they feel if you take the
solution away right that's kind of the
test
so you want them to use the solution you
use full story use whatever uh
method to see their engagement within
the platform
see where where they need help with and
there's a lot of challenge there from
without optimizing still it's a work in
progress it's a journey
it sounds like an amazing journey and
i'm inspired by by the process and and
no wonder you're saying you're working
by the book on the other hand it's very
you know it's very mythological but it's
also very critical and very rigorous and
i think that it's it's there's no
playbook into into creating a successful
company there are things that i think
you learn and that you understand along
with your very very seasoned team
and so i'm inspired to follow the
journey okay i i i need to let you run
to to build to continue building a
company but i want to take two more
minutes out of your time to ask you some
questions about yourself dutan i want
you to take me back to your childhood
and what really fascinated you as a kid
before startups before high tech
uh so i i'm i'm from the 70s so we we
had floppies and computers was a little
bit different back then
my first computer was a sinclair
uh so uh
that that
that and i'm uh there's another israeli
term called kibbutz
so i'm uh i spend my childhood in
kibbutz which is uh
i'll let you google everyone who doesn't
know google it what kibbutz is double b
um and so
this was uh computers and the fact that
i lived in an area with a lot of animals
that we had i raised pony horses this is
from a seinfeld joke i guess
so
that's my childhood
and today what inspires you
so i have a four-year-old older daughter
uh and that's
you find yourself that your life kind of
is around that and that's what
really uh
really makes me get up in the morning
and stay awake at night
and what are three words you would use
to describe yourself
oh
so
i guess i
that's a great question um
so first of all of course
yeah i don't know if
i won't go the tribal uh uh way but i'll
say first of all there's a lot of
opposites in in my in me so from i could
be extremely serious on certain terms
and extremely kind of uh
funny and uh jokish on others
i could be extremely open on certain
topics and it's really close on others
so this kind of uh
just trying to generate this balance and
which is uh
so one word could be
managing opposites or balance
and this is also true to what we're
trying to build as a culture in the
company between life and work balance
um
i'm extremely friendly so i'm well
connected there's a huge network of
friends and they're really friends
so i i would like to imagine that
if you
send me a what's up or at the middle of
the night that you're stuck with uh
i know on a highway with a flat tire uh
i'll be there for you man and the uh
thirdly i would like to say i'm a family
man um i'm really like uh
i'm i asked me 10 years ago i wouldn't
even be i wouldn't be i wasn't sure i
would ever want a kid and
today this is kind of my life so
for an amazing 20 minutes i really
appreciate it
i'm definitely gonna what's up you when
i have a flat tire and i don't know many
people who will come in the middle of
the night so now i know one and i'm i'm
gonna use it so thank you for that and
anybody who's listening i'll send you
times what's up and so thank you for
everything uh best of luck with arthur
mice continue inspiring all of us and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you very much my pleasure